So the answer to this question is that we would
expect the heritability to be higher in population one. Now why
is that? Well let's think about this for a second.
In the first population the environment is very consistent between everyone
in the population. So more of the differences in height
that we're actually able to measure are going to be due
to genetic factors than environmental ones. In the second population
though. There are a lot of environmental factors going on that
could potentially also effect height. Economic status can effect
how much food you get to eat, the quality
of that food. How much stress you're under. All
things that can impact your development, and adult height. So
more of the differences in height in the second
population are likely due to the environment more so
than in the first population. This is going to
be reflected in the overall heritability values between the populations.
Obviously genetics is still playing a role
on the population two, so the heritability
won't be zero but its likely to
be lower than the heritability in population one.